after all that hype resorts world
finally opened up for business good
evening to you on this friday thanks for
joining us
at six i'm brian loftis and i'm
christian casadas they opened to the
public
late last night and now people are
making their way to the property to get
a closer look for themselves yeah joe
mohler live outside of resorts world
he's got some of the reactions from
those that are there enjoying it
yeah a lot of people are making their
way to the north end of this trip to
check out the all new resorts where we
have watched this building
uh be built here outside and people
throughout the day have been walking out
on those sidewalks that are now open
they want to come
come up to this spot and check the uh
check out this brand new resort they go
inside
we spoke to one man who actually stayed
here last night he says this is
definitely something to see
compared to what we have in florida is
definitely a lot bigger and better
las vegas is setting the standard once
again it's pretty wild man it's a
beautiful
beautiful building after a grand night
of parties the 4.3 billion dollar
resource world finally allowed the
public inside
very open a lot of beautiful decor you
can tell it's very upscale
ryan mccormick stayed the first night we
got invited to stay on the opening night
last night it was incredible he says he
really enjoyed the hotel rooms
the best showers i think i've ever been
able to enjoy so yeah
that was great the resort is full of
options and now people are making their
way to this end of the strip to get a
peek
been to vegas quite a few times and it's
nice to see you know some luxury coming
in like this it was
it was great a lot of food options
entertainment options there's go
some say this will change this part of
the strip for years to come
took a long time for them to build it it
doesn't look like the old stardust
that's for sure
now back out here live we're taking a
look at resorts world and las vegas
boulevard people
are going inside still checking this
place out we did check the room rates
for
this evening here on this friday night
uh they're running about 400 to 500
for this friday night and throughout the
weekend uh work here at resorts world is
not
all well all the way done they're still
working on the the two clubs which will
be opening next week
for those fourth of july events and then
the theater is still under construction
as well reporting live on the strip joe
mower 8 news now